hello my name is Jan Brueghel I'm the
CEO of Wolfram a score developers of
system other today I'm going to talk
about sister mother and what's new in
version 12
okay sister mother has been developed to
model all sorts of applications it could
be model they're replacing a rat with
math it could be a modeling of a gas
turbine sometimes it's very expected
things people are doing sometimes it's
more unexpected for instance doing music
with system or the line and one of the
new features that is coming with the
next system of version has actually been
used for that purpose
today I'm going to present the new
version I will focus on three things
model creation model exchange and model
optimization so the first is how do we
get a nice word flow when we create a
new model once you have a new model a
model you want to analyze it but you
might also want to distribute it to
someone else
and so then it's important to get
exchange of models in a good way and of
course when you have a model you might
want to have maximum performance or
optimize it in some other way and that's
also an important task that we added
features for in 12
my name is Yahweh God I'm the CEO over
from a score and before I start with
those three I you might have noticed
system over twelve jumping from I think
we're on five two might be five one I
always confused if I won yeah and and we
jump to twelve so why do we do this so
let me take a step back to Mathematica
eleven three first then so in eleven
three the system and functionality of
system owner was integrated to the
Wolfram language itself this means that
even if you don't have a system or a
license you can run a lot of the system
or the functionality in a mathematic and
notebook but so as sort of an
introductory example it could be for
instance
getting in model systems inverted
pendulum I query system for this model
which is built into the system and it
will give me that answer or I could like
that I can use that to get a plot for
instance and now it takes this model it
compiles it and it will give me the plot
for some interesting signal from it I
hope so all these sort of functionality
was built into two Mathematica that's a
bug to Mathematica 11 3 that came with a
few benefits it now seamlessly
integrates with Mathematica where it
flows so other functions it's easy to
access all other functions in in the
Wolfram language and combine them where
the system over models but you can also
deploy your models to people that only
have evolved from language license so
you do your model and you do a notebook
with some exercise for instance which
we'll see soon in ankiets presentation
on virtual labs so all these things were
improved but it came with with with a
small thing that you needed to have in
order to be for this to work and when
you want to do the system or a user
interface to work together with
Mathematica you had to combine 5.1 with
Mathematica 11 3 and we will have kept
with that numbering we would have gone
to 5 2 and Mathematica 12 and it becomes
hard for people to kind of know which
ones which combinations work so that's
the main reason for actual switching but
there's also an important symbolic
reason showing that we're actually
integrating more and more and that that
is what your you should expect to see
over the over the years
ok so first I'll talk a bit about the
user interface I do that by opening the
system over interface here and start
with this example
so a
basically two masses one here mass one
which is set with a starting temperature
of 100 and mass 2 with a starting
temperature of 15 degrees Celsius then
the things in between here is different
forms of propagation of heat so we have
conduction radiation and convection so
imagine you want to understand how these
different things influence then you can
take this model and you simulate it and
get some result she will see that
eventually these two masses will have
the same temperature and you can see how
much time it will take with these on but
now you might want to know what happens
if I don't have let's say radiation then
we introduce a feature we can disable
specific components in your model so I
can click on this and I'll say disable
component and it will go gray and it
means that this is no longer part of
your model so then if I let me do this
first I'll pin this so we say this keep
that experiment and I run this again oh
sorry
should have sorry my mistake should go
from here yeah I run this again and and
I want to compare this with the old one
I drag the old version here and we see
the difference so apparently in this
case body radiation wasn't an important
factor to transfer heat between the two
it was almost the same but in this way I
can add remove different things easily
and I can even create parameters that
would control things so if I would I
added one here that his enable heat
transfer so if I set that to false all
my heat transfer is gone and if I would
simulate again then of course both
temperatures will keep at the original
so this is one of the new features
easily enabling and disabling components
another such feature let's go to a few
of the graphical views things I won't
have time to show all of them so I will
just select some yeah so we have a few
customers now see I know that make
models that are quite complex with a lot
of components a lot of wires and they're
crossing from all over the place so if
you would have this in system over five
one and try to move one component to
rearrange then the time it took for it
to calculate where all the crossings and
and modify the things was basically was
not really doable now you can take let's
say we combine take a few of these and
say I want to move these somewhere then
I can do that with ease so this makes it
easier if you're developing complex
models yeah I'll take this too if you
remove a component completely so before
if you remove that this resistor what
would happen is that all the connections
to the resistor would be gone and I will
get this and I would have to create this
connection to get the complete circuit
now we add in intelligence so we
actually understand that if we remove
this we should actually create and keep
this connection so there are all sorts
of small things that everything itself
perhaps is just one-time thing but a lot
of these things included in the user
interface to make it easier to develop
and maintain your model
I will keep that for later
sorry this one and another thing lasts a
few releases ago we added the ability to
two predefined and store plots into the
models but animation she could not do
that so this is this is a model we did
to see if people could actually bend the
ball like Beckham so it's basically a
football and a real football not they're
sort of odd football you have here so
and we try to to hit the football to
score a goal from a corner and now this
is what was open or it simulates it and
if I look at it in the animation here
it's sort of odd I have to start to kind
of sue mean I see the page and I might
play this and it's hard to see what
happens it's Ellen says go but we didn't
so I I have to find the right angles and
so on to get this to work now with the
ability to actually set camera positions
and store them into the model it looks
this way instead and and the way you do
that to store them is really easy so I
will show that too so here it
automatically starts to play with the
camera angle that we shows and following
the object object that we chose and we
also chose to put it on repeat go yes
there's you're not Mexican right and you
could of course then start to reassess
to really see the goal but you can also
save several different cameras so I can
say now I'll have the ball camera I can
take the overview camera and I've saved
that too and now I can see it from
another angle so I can set up as
different view spots and I'll get that
automatically I don't have to redo that
everything time I show the model good so
yeah there are a bunch of those things
in the graphic
user interface if afterwards you
download the presentation notebook I
have a large list it's not complete but
it's a larger list or which things are
actually added to the user interface and
for that matter for the other things I'm
presenting to so so then exchanging
models once you created a model
exchanging models before we had a
possibility to export models in
something called FM use for
co-simulation meaning that we export a
model with the actual solver in it so
other software's that might not even
have us over can actually use that run
that and sync with with whatever they
are doing but we couldn't import in the
same way so now we added that so we can
take a look at basically how that works
the whole whole flow oh I actually yeah
let's do this
hopefully nope that's obviously played
around here a bit before so let me just
take a new copy of it tying system and I
should go into spell tank system from
yeah let's take that one go for that why
doesn't want to cope again
let's put it there okay
that was not the one I was aiming for
this was probably yeah sorry okay so
here we have it I could then take one of
these tanks this is basic tanks that
you've tried to control the level of
water in and suppose I wanted to export
one of these tanks I can open it and
I'll say file export as functional
mock-up unit which is standard used by
many tools and I'll export it and I can
save it somewhere for instance in my
downloads just tip it to my folder of
junk so I'll replace that now once I so
as said we exporting it with the actual
solver in it so we have to compile and
everything like that before we export it
and now if I instead import it again
so file import fmu tank like this and it
gives me a name tank fnu yes let's
replace that so they will have the new
one it looks similar but it has the
symbol showing that that is it's a it's
a time so now what I can do is I'll
replace this and I can do that with a
small trick rather than removing it and
replacing it that way I can say change
component type and take this tank FM you
put it here and add it like that so now
we have the new tank which is the
co-simulation version and CANSIM will
like this the important thing of that of
course it's not that I can reinforce
something that I did is system other
already is that I can import something
done in some other tool and it doesn't
have to be a model like a tool it can be
all sorts of tools there's there's 56
two different software's that can do
different forms of FM u FM I exchange
it works on different platforms but you
have to export it from the right
platform yep
looking here at a time I'll do this very
quickly we have improved symbolic
linearization quite a lot so symbolic
linearization means that I can take the
models typically creating system of our
very nonlinear and it is this in this
case we have an inverted pendulum and
one of our standard examples and if I
take that very pendulum at that and i
linearize it in in Mathematica then I
will get there a while localizing model
it says basically it's it's creating the
smallest version of the model around the
point that we chose to linearize around
and then we're creating the transfer
function model or systems or the state
space model whatever we have set as our
preference took a bit of time like that
the neat thing though is that we can set
things as parameters instead so we can
choose to keep things symbolic so if I
say here method symbolic derivative
symbolic parameters inverted pendulum D
then instead of getting only numeric
values I can keep parts of it symbolic
this means that for instance if I would
like to design a controller with
different options that was depending on
on the dimension of my pendulum then I
can keep this parameter and play around
with that in Mathematica
no not directly no okay then optimizing
models was the third thing I was going
to talk about and this is if if the
modeling stuff that I started with is
really for everyone and this is more for
someone that is really trying to
optimize the system so it's a bit more
advanced it can be used in for many
different reasons
for instance understanding the behavior
of simulation better it can be used for
improved performance or to do a better
linearization or in the study better
that's what just one couple of cases and
this is where audio comes in I will give
an example one of my colleagues
Leonardo Laguna Reese he creates sounds
or he creates filters for making music
and what he does he basically takes the
old classic real analog filters
re-implement them in system over we drag
and drop and then he tries to reduce
those equations to the most efficient
set possible in order to be able to
simulate this in real time and with as
many filters as possible so if we look
at that one of the things he he did when
doing this he had an amplifier with
distortion that he wanted to to model
and he did the top one there but the
right one was this one and we will see
what differs right now well there's
colors kind of indicating where the
errors will appear he didn't know that
from the beginning his approach when
doing this the things that are marked I
would red and green are transistors
these transistor models looked like this
so he used a transistor model a well
known transistor model called the ever
small model and it's it's it's developed
to be a minimalistic ideal version of
transistor
so it contains these two diodes and some
gains and so on
so using this model he tried to simulate
the system so similars here and we will
see I said he wants to have this real
time does this look real time speed for
decreasing 343 microseconds per second
so that's far from real time it's like
not even close so let's stop that
doesn't really wear it Cass we want
right oh did we map my my my keyboard
that happened some time ago
okay so then a let's look at the
modeling system modeler this is the
model with the red dots I'll simulate it
again in system molar and we will see
the same behavior that it's slow and and
this will take us now to the Bloch
equation browser so let me stop this
you see it's five to the power minus
three is super slow too so the new tool
here is the equation block browser and
this is a small model so it doesn't have
many things but what is what it shows is
the equations that are or the system of
equations that that you get from your
model in this case it shows is basically
how one big block it's in blue which
means that it's a nonlinear equation so
if we click on that it will show us how
the different variables depend on each
other in this block of equations and we
see there are four blue dots here these
four blue dots represents the nonlinear
parts of our equations the green dots
are different kind of linear systems and
if we click on the blue dot here and
this is very small you can't see it on
the owner when I Hoover over somewhere
we might see it it says which which
variable we're talking about but it also
selects the corresponding equation so
this fully owner know when he saw this
and it happens to be that all these four
blue dots have similar equations just
for each of each of these transistors
it's where the diode is where he gets
this problem and Leonardo is not a
mathematician
he's more he knows his electronics so we
know the physics behind it okay what the
typical thing typical difference in the
different models in in when you do
transistor models
well you can ask actually add
transistors or capacitors to your model
so that's exactly what he did he added
these two small capacitors with
corresponds to the capacitance of the
wires and as he sort of knew he was
directed by the equations this is
somewhere here is where you should look
and he has to know which about his area
he could know that if he would have been
in thermodynamics he might have been
thinking I need a heat capacitance
freeze or if it would have been in
hydraulics some volume things like that
and now by adding that he could get from
this sort of set of equations it could
be reduced to this one so despite adding
these components the system to solve
which much easier to solve and if we
simulate it this building in progress we
hope that it can reach real time oh
there you go
interpreting unit it's actually done
know what happened here it's done
simulate simulating I don't and there
you go there's some some bug hearing in
my 12 version apparently but it
immediately kind of the result was
simulating one second the actual
simulation is much shorter than one
second now with that small of a change
so then the question is what did he
actually see with that let's listen to
it I hope we get some sound here you
sound on four it doesn't seem like it
works let's plug it like that
there they play your house here yeah
let's see the master volume is on but
this doesn't give anything odd let's try
again
good sound go no I
it was supposed to do but I I
disconnected it
so anyways we'll have to fix that for
the next presentation because uncle will
be trying to do that and I'm running out
of time so this is actually playing
music you don't hear it but sorry for
that you can go to youtube afterwards
and and when you download there's a link
to it so basically we worked on model
creation many things to make it easier
to create models model exchange and then
model optimization to be able to do
things like music thank you very much
[Applause]